بالحضن يا ابن عمي فلننسى الماضي ولنحرق
ورقه العداء التي ارهقتنا بها امريكا
وصدعت رؤوسنا بها اما انا لنا ان نتحد
لنواجه التحديات نحن نتحدث عن ايران
والسعوديه هو ليس مسلسل العشق الممنوع بل
هي سياسه العالم الجديده وهي التي فرضت
ونثرت اوراق اللاعبين ليتم ترتيبها من
جديد الاصابع الايرانيه تشير محذره
للسعوديه منطقه ناهيه الهدف هم يستهدفون
شرق اسيا ولكن لن يمر وبعيون ضيقه ونظرات
حاده العين الاولى ترمق السعوديه والعين
الاخره تتوجه صوب ايران لا تدعوهم يقتربوا
من حدودكم فالسياسه الامريكيه تعيش على
شرب الدم وبيع الاسلحه للدول المتناحره
الحكمه الصينيه تصيب هدفها بدقه امريكا
تعلن عن انشاء نيتو اسوي والهدف مضايقه
الصين والنيل من الاعداء اذا ما هو الحل
تقولها ايران السعوديه لترد روسيا فلتعلن
تحالفكما وعن حلف عسكري جديد امريكا تضرب
على خديها لتقول لبريطانيا فلتقرصيني كي
افيق من هذا الكابوس نعم عن تحالف ايران
والسعوديه العسكري نتحدث وللقصه بقيه
تتعلم ظلت امريكا وصيه على اسيا شرقها
وغربها وشمالها مع الجنوب بدات الريح
العاتيه بالهبوب وسلط تسحب جيشها من
افغانستان بعد ان انسحبت من العراق بينما
تبقي على قله من جنودها في سوريا لكن في
المقابل دول اسيا لم تضيع وقتها عبثا
فصينو تبني نفسها منذ عقود والهدف ليس
اخراج امريكا من المنطقه بل الخروج من
البوتقه المحليه والاتجاه نحو قمه العالم
ورحله الالف ميل تبدا بخطوه اسابيع قليله
بعد الانسحاب الامريكي المفاجئ من
افغانستان والذي اثار موجه انتقادات عنيفه
من الحلفاء الاستراتيجيين الولايات
المتحده لتعلن الاخيره عن تحالف امني
استراتيجي مع كل من استراليا وبريطانيا
تحت مسمى تحالف اوكوس ما الذي يخطط له
الامريكان اولا سحبوا قواتهم ثم انشات
تحالفا جديدا اليس امرا مريبا نعم واشنطن
كثف التحركاتها زادت من حلفائها رغبت
ورهبت هددت وحذرت كل ذلك ضمن استراتيجيه
جديده والهدف دائما وابدا مجابهه التنين
الاحمر الصيني صعود صيني مرعب اكبر امريكا
على اقامه تحالفات امنيه وعسكريه في نطاق
ضيق وتحالف اوكوس خير دليل لكن ذلك لا
يكفي فعقدت واشنطن شركات مع دول من منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وكل ذلك حتى لا
تدخل امريكا في مواجهه مباشره مع الصين
وبالرغم من ان الاعلان عن التحالف لم يحمل
اي اشاره صريحه الى الصين الا ان التحالف
الذي يمتد جغرافيا من الولايات المتحده
الى المحيط مرورا باوروبا لم يكن من الصعب
فهم ان عنوانه الرئيسي هو مواجهه صعود
الصين ومساعيها بان تصبح القوه الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه المهيمنه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ الامر لم ينتهي عند ذلك بل
ان امريكا اعلنت تزويد استراليا باسطول من
الغواصات المتقدمه التي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه وهي المره الثانيه التي تشارك
فيها الولايات المتحده تقنياتها النوويه
المتطوره بعد مشاركتها لصالح بريطانيا مع
التعاون المشترك في مجال التكنولوجيا
العسكريه الجديده بما يشمل الامن
السيبراني والذكاء الاصطناعي والصواريخ
التي تفوق سرعه الصوت فما كل هذا السخاء
من ابناء العم سام الاجابه واضحه فكل ذلك
جاء من اجل حصار الصين وان كان ذلك بكسر
القوانين الدوليه للاسلحه لا يمكن تكرار
النيتو الصين كانت قوه صاعده نعم لكنها
صعدت بالفعل واصبحت تتحدى الولايات
المتحده مجله عسكريه عديده لتفقد واشنطن
تفوقها في منطقه المحيط الهادئ وهذا ليس
كلامنا انما هو تقرير جديد اصدره مركز
الدراسات الامريكيه في جامعه سدن
الاستراليه ليشير التقرير الى ان ترسانه
الاسلحه الهائله التي تمتلكها بكين تهدد
القواعد الاساسيه التي تمتلكها الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وان مثل هذه القواعد
يمكن اعتبارها بلا فائده مع بدايه الضربات
الجويه في الساعات الاولى لاي صراع بكين
خرجت من قوقعتها الهادئه لتفتح اعينها
الضيقه وتتحدث بلهجه شديده في وجوه
الامريكان قائله انتم تخططون لنسخه اسيويه
من حلف شمال الاطلسي وهذا الامر لن يؤدي
سوى الى اغراق منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
في زوبعه من النزاعات والصراعات انتم
تريدون ازمه اخرى كالتي تشهدها اوكرانيا
نعم ابناء شيبينغ يقولونها ويكررونها يجب
لا ننسى الكوارث الخطيره التي سببتها
الحربان العالميتان لشعوب كل البلدان ويجب
الا نسمح لهذا التاريخ الماساوي بان يعيد
نفسه هي رساله صينيه بان لا تراجع ولا
تحالف مع الغرب في منطقه الخاصه ولن نسمح
لكم بتلويثها
بتحالفاتكم المسموعه ايران تدخل على الخط
منتصف عام 2022 الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
يشد رحاله للمره الاولى نحو الشرق الاوسط
ممسكا احلامه بيديه والهدف جمع موافقات
دوليه عربيه لمنع ايران من الحصول على
سلاح نووي والحلم الاخر صنع نيتو عربي
لتحتوي سياستها التوسعيه في المنطقه على
ان نشمل هذا الحلف دول الخليج ومعها مصر
والاردن والعراق اضافه الى اسرائيل لكن
عندما ربط بيض سياسته باضافه تل ابيب بهذا
الحلف لم يكن يعلم بان الشرق الاوسط لن
ينضم لحلف يضم الكيان وكما يقول اراد ان
يكحلها فاعماها وتلك الجهود الضخمه التي
سعت بها واشنطن لنجاح الناتو الاطلسي لا
تزال غائبه عن الشرق الاوسط ايران طوت
صفحه الماضي وبدلا عن زياده حده التوترات
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه اخذت طهران
خطوه معاكسه لم تتوقعها واشنطن فالتقى
الايرانيون مع السعوديين لعلاج هذا الصدع
السياسي والعسكري برعايه الجراح الصيني
لتنجح العمليه السياسيه وينتج عن اتفاق
تاريخي مفاده ان المنطقه ليست بحاجه
لوصايه امريكيه وان احتاجت المنطقه للقوه
فالصين موجوده وليس هناك داعا للتدخل
الامريكي مرت الايام وقوات واشنطن تسرح
وتمرح متناسيه صفعه الصلح الايراني
السعودي وما ستترتب عليه من عواقب ستؤدي
لقطع الايادي الامريكيه من المياه الدوليه
ايران والسعوديه ومع قليل من القبلات
الحاره ها هي ايران تزيد طين واشنطن بالله
حيث اعلنت عن تشكيل التحالف عسكري مشترك
للبحريه الايرانيه مع دول المنطقه بما في
ذلك السعوديه والامارات وقطر والبحرين
والعراق لتخلو المنطقه قريبا من اي قوه
خارج هذا الحلف المعلن لنقولها معا باي
باي امريكا مهلا تعالوا لنرتب هذه الاوراق
ايران حليفه للصين وروسيا وهي اليوم حليفه
للسعوديه وباقي الدول العربيه لتنفض
امريكا غبار الخيبه ويعلنها المتحدث باسم
قياده الاسطول الخامس تيم هوكينز ان
التحالف الذي اعلنت ايران واعتزامها
تشكيله مع السعوديه ودول خليجيه اخرى امر
غير منطقي ويتحدى العقل ليضيفه هي المسؤول
الاول عن عدم الاستقرار الاقليمي وتريد
تشكيله تحالف املي بحري لحمايه المياه
التي تهددها على حد قوله اذا اردت ان تامن
الثعلب فلتسلمه مفاتيح القن لانه سيكون
المسؤول ان نقص من القني دجاجه
الصين القاضيه اصاب واشنطن وحلفائها
الاوروبيين الرعب بسبب مبادره الصين طريق
الحرير الجديد البالغه الف مليار دولار عن
اي ارقام نتحدث يا لها من ميزانيه ضخمه
لكن هذا الطريق سيربط الكتله الاقتصاديه
لحوالي 70 دوله خارج سيطره الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقضي المبادره ببناء
خطوط السكك الحديديه والطرق وخطوط انابيب
الغاز التي ستكون مرتبطه بروسيا الى غايه
العام 2017 الصين هي ايضا بصدد ان تكون
القوه الاقتصاديه العالميه الاولى خلال
هذا العقد مسيحتنا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن عرش الصداره وليس ذلك وحسب
فاذا كانت كل من الصين وايران والهند ودول
اخرى ستتحرر عاجلا او اجلا من الدولار
الامريكي باعتبارها عمله احتياطيه عالميه
ومن جمعيه الاتصالات الماليه العالميه بين
البنوك فهذا سيؤدي الى هبوط الا قيمه
الدولار وانهيار مالي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبمحاوله لرد الاعتبار هنا
واشنطن تحاول الرد على الصين وحلفائها حين
حاولت ضم اليابان لحلف الناتو منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ بين المصالح
الامريكيه من جانب والصعود الصيني والصحوه
الايرانيه من جانب اخر بخطوات اثارت رعب
امريكيا حقيقيا فكيف سيجابه الامريكان
التحالفات الجديده
[موسيقى]